a lot of people as I talked about
yesterday that you would not think of as
politicians people from the media people
from the tech world uh people that were
not traditional DC uh creatures they
started appearing in politics I was one
of the first people to interview Blake
Masters I think it was July of 2021 when
basically nobody knew him there were a
whole bunch of other Republicans running
and it didn't it I mean most people did
not think that this guy was going to do
anything well it looks like by the end
of tonight he might just be the next
senator from Arizona here is a Blake
Masters portion of a Blake Masters
campaign ad that I thought just just was
just right just right
Rising prices mean that we all have to
take a second look at our shopping lists
set priorities so let's look at Mark
Kelly's how about hiring 18 000 new
border patrol agents does that sound
good
well Mark Kelly voted no what are you
doing said he voted for 87 000 new IRS
agents Mark Kelly kept our border wide
open but he's sending Tax Collectors
coming after you
I'm Blake Masters died from this message
Blake is a good dude I've gotten to know
him quite well he's a good dude and the
message there like pick one we're going
to do something with agents you want
border agents in a place like Arizona to
protect the Border make sure that
illegals aren't rampaging across the
border and committing crime and all of
that stuff or do you want IRS agents do
you want 87 000 new IRS agents some of
whom are armed to look into more
Americans to find out where they can
squeeze more money out of you the
message is pretty freaking simple and we
saw a poll this morning that for the
first time timing is everything for the
first time Blake Masters is actually
leading in the polls as of this morning
so we shall see what happens in Arizona